[Musique]
c'est à la villa du département que la
présidente nassimah dindar a remis les
attestations de formation à neuf
contrats uniques d'insertion qui
partiront prochainement travailler dans
la zone océan indien en contrat
d'insertion destiné aux personnes
qualifiées bénéficiaires du rsa en
recherche d'emploi nous mettons en
oeuvre et nous donnons à voir la
politique d'insertion du conseil
départemental
ce sont des gens qui touchaient le rsa
et qui part dans ces huits alors qu'ils
ont des diplômes alors qu'ils portent
des projets de vie un projet de vie
personnelle qui peut devenir également
le projet collectif que la france
réunion porte sur les échanges en termes
de coopération éducatifs culturels
sportifs francophonie également dans le
domaine social et nous l'espérons dans
le domaine économique
une opportunité pour ces réunionnais
qualifiés qui grâce à cette expérience
auront une employabilité augmenter et
s'inséreront plus facilement dans la vie
professionnelle je pars à madagascar
plus précisément rien en dessous pour
faire assistante
animateur pardonne deux clubs de
français dans un lycée bagages je vais
partir au mozambique dans la capitale
maputo pour être chargé projets en
français langue étrangère et en sciences
au centre culturel franco mozambique à
tout va est nouveau pour moi donc ça va
être un terrain d'apprentissage
gigantesque va me permettre d' accueil
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de nouvelles
compétences et aussi d'élargir le réseau
professionnel j'ai la chance de partir à
sion l'île sainte-marie à madagascar en
tant qu'animatrice d'éducation à
l'environnement c'est nous conte unités
de pouvoir aller échanger avec les pays
voisins les pays de la zone dans le
cadre de tout ce qui est développement
durable de tout ce qui est environnement
le conseil départemental contribuer
ainsi à la stratégie de coopération
éducative de la réunion dans l'océan
indien avec le recrutement et la mise à
disposition de personnes qualifiées au
profit de pays de la francophonie
[Musique]